ai figli tuoi figli
e poi ho finito quando lo fate ha
intenzione di fare dei figli
figli figli figli figli bigli
essere una donna con un utero
funzionante o meno non ha importanza
significa passare dai 15 ai 20 anni
della propria vita a giustificarne la
mancata occupazione
è successo anche a me ovviamente mi è
successo in famiglia mi è successo in
contesti professionali mi è successo tra
amici mi è successo durante le
interviste televisive ecco io vorrei la
fierezza di quelle che ti guardano con
occhio fermo e ti dicono a me i bambini
non piacciono e io di figli non ne farò
mai
io quella fierezza lì non ce l'avevo a
20 anni
non ce l'ho neanche adesso che ne ho
quasi 50 e la gente ha smesso di
scocciarmi per sopraggiunti limiti d'età
anche perché sarebbe una bugia
abbiamo americano tantissimo sono una
calamità per i bambini sono lin stati a
di tutti i ragazzini che mi si
avvicinano ci gioco ci chiacchieroni
sorveglio sono brava a calmarli quando
piangono
ho imparato anche non preoccuparmi
quando rovinano al suolo perché non
hanno il pieno controllo degli arti
inferiori
soffio nasi cambio pannolini dopo acini
sulla boa imbocco di papà bullock e non
so non mi faccio sputare in mano
alimenti sgraditi e anche vomitare sui
piedi tutte cose realmente accadute
insomma io ho le piene funzionalità di
un adulto nell'atto di interfacciarsi
con i minori
eppure non ho figli non ne ho avuti non
ne avrò l'aneddotica familiare riporta
una conversazione fra mia madre e mia
sorella e me
all'incirca fra i 7 e gli 8 anni ho
paura a chiedere conferma in cui avrei
detto non so con quanta fierezza ma di
sicuro con una certa spietata
determinazione
io ho figli non ne farò mai non voglio
mica fare la fine che ha fatto tu
è confortante sapere di aver toccato
l'apice
proprio perfidia in così tenera età
perché io giuro che carogna così non lo
sono mai stata non ero mai stata prima e
non lo sono mai stata
dopo la cosa divertente che sempre
secondo mia madre e mia sorella che
allora era piccolina le avrebbe detto
non ti preoccupare i mama te lo faccio
io un bambino è stata di parola ne ha
fatti tre
non è questione di opportunità mancate i
compagni stabilità fertile c'erano e
allora perché non ho avuto figli e buffo
che la domanda non si sa mai perché mai
avrei dovuto averne perché per me e per
altre mie coetanee anche l'idea di avere
dei figli era un po come che ne so fare
bungee jumping scala del k2 fare il giro
del mondo in barca a vela che poi la
vera non è io dei reni però ci siamo
capiti
terrificante
faticoso pure costoso magari bello eh ma
il tempo di cera e la voglia di non
dormire soprattutto
tutti i genitori che ho conosciuto nella
mia vita
sembravano degli zombie felici ma vivi
per miracolo io se non dopo una notte
non due non tre una il giorno dopo sono
intrattabile odio tutti e non faccio
altro che sbadigliare figuriamoci non
dormire per tre anni quando va bene
i miei genitori mi rinfacciano ancora le
notti insonni dei miei primi mesi di
vita in cui per farmi dormire bisognano
a prendermi e mettere in macchina
e partire
non mettermi in macchina e accendere il
motore no
bisognava proprio muoversi
tornando alla questione principale
perché dovremmo avere dei figli
dato che non viviamo più nelle case
caserme ciao la rifaccio
dato che non dormiamo più nelle caverne
e che la contraccezione esiste
perché dovremmo scegliere di farli
possiamo decidere come disporre del
nostro utero
quindi
a meno che non li voglia tantissimo a
quel punto va bene tutto perché ogni
scelta è lecita ma quante sono quelle
che li fanno per mancanza di alternative
e quella che invece li fanno per
bellissima vocazione allora mettiamola
così fra i 30 e 40 anni ci stavo
cascando anch'io
era un periodaccio una figlia di un
lavoro che mi piaceva moltissimo era
stato molto faticoso e aveva lasciato un
buco enorme nella mia vita professionale
mi dico forse dovrei fare un figlio
potrei fare un figlio così per ipotesi
non è che avessi molto altro da fare
vado alla mia ginecologa
e le racconto questa cosa che dico mi sa
che l'orologio biologico
lei mi guarda ride scuote la testa qui
devo specificare che la mia ginecologa
romana altrimenti sembrano ricostruzione
fantasiosa
l'orologio biologico
scusa la franchezza è
è una di quelle cose che si sono
avventati mettendo in trappola i figli
li fai se li vuoi fa e se ti vengono se
no no
il sollievo
non ero io
non è un orologio biologico
quel peso che sentivo sullo stomaco che
erano quei due tre quintali di
oppressione patriarcale scagliati via
con un gesto casuale dalla donna
incaricata di vegliare sul corretto
funzionamento del mio apparato
riproduttivo
non credo sia un caso che tutti i
discorsi sul crollo delle nascite siano
accompagnati da discorsi sempre
pressoché identici
sull'utilizzo di incentivi finanziari
che finora hanno avuto un impatto sulla
natalità pari a zero nonché da tentativi
più o meno scoperti di toglierci la
facoltà di scegliere se diventare un
meno madri
perché se una ci pensa troppo e può
decidere
facile che decida di no
sono anni che in italia si parla di
congedi di paternità retribuiti e
obbligatori
sapete chi scrive le leggi sapete chi le
fa votare le porta in parlamento
le donne
nella vana speranza che gli uomini 6
interessino finora non è successo
fatevi due conti
e pieno di gente là fuori che pensa che
diventare genitori sia una cosa che
succede
naturale
molti sono uomini e mi dispiace dirlo
così ma naturale proprio no amici
il mal di denti e naturale
un sacco di dolore sono naturali la
gravidanza e faticosissima si vomita si
sviluppano le caviglie fi pp ogni due
minuti ti fa mai la schiena questo
quando va bene
il parto fa male nel senso di un male
bestia che voi sprovvisti di utero non
vi potete neanche immaginare se per caso
ti tagliano per far passare meglio il
capoccione di un neonato particolarmente
robusto poi ti devono ricucire e i ponti
tirano
se volete provare
immaginatevelo voi a casa avete presente
quella parte che va dallo strato
all'anno il perineo per voi maschi è
come lo togliamo per il lungo e poi velo
rammendiamo che si offre volontario poi
c'è l'allattamento
con annesse ragadi al seno provateci voi
a no non potete e poi c'è tutta quella
fatica immane che si fa per anni e che
lei stata certifica essere quasi tutta
sulle nostre spalle
insomma abc il cui contributo alla
riproduzione si estende poco in là oltre
l'inseminazione
chiedete dove dovete andare voi alla
natura
in assenza di una vocazione totale
assoluta alla maternità i figli sono una
fregatura sì certo l'amore la felicità
che ti danno
almeno fino ai dolci 13 anni poi si
trasformano i bronci con le gambe e ti
odiano prescindere e comunque la prole
non ha alcun dovere verso chi la mette
al mondo i genitori che si riproducono
per avere qualcosa che sia amore
sicurezza
compagnie a riconoscimento all'interno
di comunità molto chiuse soldi o sgravi
fiscali
servono solo dal lavoro agli
psicoterapeuti che dovranno occuparsi di
rappezzare i loro danni ai figli
bisognerebbe solo e soltanto dare e
sperare che qualcosa di quello che si dà
ti torna indietro
i figli si fanno in due si dice però
solo le donne viene chiesto di
collocarsi da una parte o dall'altra
all'interno all'esterno dello stesso
sottoinsieme madri e non
anzi per gli esperti di demografia
le donne si dividono in due grandi
sottocategorie quelle che hanno fatto
figli per pagare le pensioni e tutte le
altre
tenda del prt
non sono mai stata incinta
neanche per sbaglio neanche per un
momento mi sono domandata ogni tanto che
madre sarah è stata e la risposta è
ansiosa alle tele maiuscole perché io
sono fatta 75 per cento di ansia
condizioni di riposo figuriamoci se
avessi avuto la responsabilità di un
micro umano che urla piange vomita
strilla vuole essere nutrito ogni tre
ore fino a tre anni non sa fare neanche
la pipì in autonomia obito ho avuto una
vita emotiva e relazionale piena e
nonostante non abbia mai espresso né
rammarico nell'impianto per le scelte la
domanda ma non ti piacerebbe fare un
figlio mi ha accompagnata per tutta la
mia vita adulta per poi essere
sostituita da ma non ti dispiace non
averne avuti perché come mi dicevano le
parenti femmine quando ero già
giovanissima euro già riluttante
poi te ne penti
poi te ne penti è la minaccia sospesa
sopra la testa di tutte le donne tutte
si dice che chi non sa gonadi femminili
percepisca il tempo in maniera diversa
niente mestruazioni ricordati che sono
passati al 3 4 settimane
niente in una pausa come il fischio
finale
fertilità oltranza ti credo che si
sentono sempre ragazzini mentre a noi
tocca decidere in fretta perché poi te
ne penti
[Musica]
me l'hanno ripetuto a vent'anni
me l'hanno ripetuto a 30 anni me l'hanno
detto pure a 40 e ora ne ho cose 50 e
dico dove sto pentimento peccato che non
fumo dovrei fare come si fa con gli
autobus romani che per atipici una
paglia e quelli che girano l'angolo
non sono pentita
ma se dovessi dire cosa ho provato
quando le mie ovaie hanno chiuso i
battenti
ecco è stato più
non potrò più cambiare idea
non è
stato una sensazione di perdita quanto
il senso di una porta che si chiude è
stato più simile a quando quello che ti
succede quando capisci che per certe
cose sei troppo grande e troppo tardi e
certi treni non torneranno più
non è quanto mi dispiace non aver fatto
dei figli un po mi dispiace non avere
più con l'opzione è la malinconia di
aver vissuto più di metà della mia vita
non il rimpianto di non avere generato
dei piccoli umani con le mie sembianze
anche perché appunto
ci ha pensato mia sorella per cui il
fantastico miracolo della genetica per
cui tra di noi non ci somigliamo granché
ma scomposte e ricomposte ricompare
chiamo nei suoi figli ei miei nipoti io
rivedo
pari pari i miei tratti fisici e
caratteriali a una timidezza un altro la
cocciutaggine un'altra precocità qui ci
sono le orecchie e il naso la magrezza
le lentiggini ci somigliamo siamo
famiglia
e loro mi aspettano con ansia ogni volta
che devo tornare ogni volta che torno a
casa dei miei genitori non dormo si
agitano quando arrivi sia poi andiamo a
prendere la zia
e insomma questo corpo così poco
leggiadro così poco decorativo così poco
funzionale
alla poetica e alla retorica per cui se
le donne non ci fossero il mondo sarebbe
un posto molto più brutto oltre non
decorare granché sì anche sottratto al
suo fine ultimo cioè quello di fare
figli per la patria
non ho fatto felice il patriarcato ma il
patriarcato bisogna dare solo dispiaceri
e non ho fatto felice l'inps spiace
l'inps però fatto tradizione stessa a
volte tantissimo a volte meno quasi mai
pensando che se avessi fatto dei figli
tutto magicamente sarebbe andato a posto